ten people
[Music]
okay good afternoon to everybody now as
everyone here knows whoops get your
footing or your kneeing or whatever it
is so as everyone knows we've all been
sworn in by the Chief Justice of the
United States to serve as judges and
jurors in the impeachment trial of
President Trump when the Chief Justice
walked in you could feel a weight at the
moment I saw members on both sides of
the aisle visibly gulp the weight of
history sits on shoulders and produces
sometimes results you never know will
happen for some of us here this is the
first time we've done this for others
like myself it's the second time but I
assure you there's no difference even
though I've gone through this before for
all of us the solemnity gravity of the
moment in our history hits you square in
the back when you take that oath a
separate oath designed by the Senate
only four senators who will serve on a
court of impeachment the feeling in the
Senate chamber was solemn serious
profound the weight of history the eyes
of history you feel it are upon you I
know every one of my colleagues felt it
I hope my colleagues on the other side
of the aisle filter you all heard the
reading of the articles of impeachment
by representative shift at noon it was a
solemn recitation of charges that
approved our crimes against our
democracy itself to actually hear the
charges read even though we've heard the
many times before impresses the
seriousness
of the charges this is not something
trivial this is not something everybody
does this is not something that can be
dismissed President Donald Trump is
accused of coercing a foreign leader
into interfering in our elections and
then doing everything in his power to
cover it up these are exactly the kind
of offenses the founders most feared
when they Forge the impeachment clause
in the Constitution
do we want foreign powers to determine
our elections to the American people
want someone from overseas determining
who's their president who's their
governor who's their senator who's their
Congressman this is what the nation has
feared for centuries and we fear it
today more than ever with this president
on someone from oversea serious stuff
this is not trivial because it's hard to
imagine a greater subversion of our
democracy than four powers outside our
borders to determine the elections
within our borders and for a country to
attempt such a thing on its own as
Russia has done is bad enough for an
American president to deliberately
solicit such a thing to blackmail a
foreign country with military assistance
to help them win an election is
unimaginably worse I am actually filled
with anger when you read the attempt to
subvert our democracy so these charges
are serious very and it's on those
charges which the Senate has to render a
verdict remarkably crucial pieces of
information related to the charges
against the president are still coming
out last night left poorness and
associate of the president's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani
gave an astonishing interview on
national television that further
implicated the president in a plot to
remove the US ambassador and pressure
ukrainian president selects liz olenski
into announcing investigations into one
of the president's leading rivals and
just today through the good work of
chris van hollen who you'll hear from
shortly the GAO found that it was
illegal illegal for President Trump to
withhold military assistance from
Ukraine to pressure them to interfere in
the 2020 elections both the revelations
about mr. Parnas and the GAO opinion
strengthen our push for witnesses and
documents in the trial
the GAO opinion especially makes clear
that the documents we requested in our
letter to leader McConnell are even more
needed now than when we requested it
last month because President Trump
simply put broke the law every senator
will get a chance to vote to obtain
these documents next week now returning
to how I began the oath we all just took
will weigh heavily on senators to
consider this question about half
because president Truong misses and
three specific sets of relevant
documents the witnesses are not
Democrats they are the president's men
his top advisors who he appointed the
documents are not democratic documents
they are just documents period every
Senate impeachment trial in our history
all 15 that were brought to completion
featured witnesses every single one
leader McConnell is fond of citing
precedent
we've all heard him about 1999 the
precedent in impeachment trials in the
Senate is to have witnesses to have no
kisses would be a dramatic break with
precedent it would mean the first
impeachment trial of a president in
history with no witnesses
the first impeachment trial of anybody
that went to completion in the Senate's
two hundred and some-odd year history
without witnesses so in the coming days
each of us every one of us Democrat and
Republican will face a choice about
whether to begin this trial in the
search of truth or in service of the
president's desire to cover it up now
that every senator has sworn a solemn
oath before God and the American people
to do impartial justice let every
senator reflect on that choice and let
history weigh on every one of our
shoulders senator Harris I would argue
that not only is this an impeachment
trial but that the the very integrity of
the United States Senate is on trial
what is before us our charges that are
arguably the most serious charges that
have ever been leveled against a
president of the United States and where
there has been an abandonment of
responsibility to uphold the ideals much
less the words of the United States
Constitution by the President of the
United States that responsibility now
rests on the shoulders of each member of
the United States Senate which is to
uphold the integrity of our system of
democracy uphold the integrity of our
system of justice and to uphold the
integrity of the United States Senate
which has a responsibility to do fair
and impartial justice fades response
evidence documents and individuals who
are witnesses so that we can engage in a
fair deliberation and make a decision
that reflects the ideals and the values
and the very principles of the United
States system of justice and so that is
but what is before us today
and we took a very solemn oath it's a
very serious matter which each of us
should take responsibly and take
seriously understanding that whatever
the party affiliation of the President
of the United States right now it is
incumbent on the United States Senate to
do the work of upholding America's
Constitution and our very system of
justice Thank You senator Schumer's
senator Harris raising my right hand and
swearing to do impartial justice was a
solemn moment a solemn moment for all of
us a moment when the very weight of
history becomes clear to be in the
chamber as the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court
strode up to the podium and took his
oath to do impartial justice made clear
the gravity and the historic nature of
this moment over this coming weekend we
really have two questions that I think
our colleagues need to wrestle with one
is is this going to be a trial there's a
simple reality in America trials have
evidence and cover-ups do not trials
have evidence they have documents they
have witnesses that are relevant to the
matter in front of us and leadership has
by letter asked that we consider four
different witnesses who are directly
relevant who were senior leaders in this
administration who were in the room on
the email chain and could testify if
they testify truthfully to whether the
President did or did not inappropriately
block aid to Ukraine as has been charged
this is a big departure from previous
investigations of presidents for
impeachment that President Trump has
used an overly broad assertion of
executive privilege to try and block
critical testimony
President Clinton even President Nixon
directed his closest advisors and his
cabinet officials to cooperate with an
investigation which leads to the second
issue the second article is obstruction
of Congress the president has to decide
is he going to present a defense
President Clinton even president nixon's
you know Jenna passed and that's
something that is extraordinary
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
special to me and the people that are
gathered around me this afternoon we're
proudly announcing historic steps to
protect the First Amendment right to
pray in public schools so you have the
right to pray and that's a very
important and powerful right there's
nothing more important than that I would
say we're joined by the secretary
Betsy DeVos deputy attorney general
Jeffrey Rosen and students and advocates
from across America and advocates they
were they've been calling and writing by
the thousands and you're representing
that large group of people in a sacred
principle of our republic that
government must never stand between the
people and god yet in public schools
around the country authorities are
stopping students and teachers from
praying sharing their faith or following
their religious beliefs it is totally
unacceptable you see it on the football
field you see it so many times where
they're stopped from praying and we are
doing something to stop that tragically
there is a growing totalitarian impulse
on the far left that seeks to punish
restrict and even prohibit religious
expression something that if you go back
10 years or 15 years or 20 years it was
unthought-of that a thing like that
could even happen that anybody would
even think of something like that
happening that is why today my
administration is issuing strong new
guidance to protect religious liberty in
our public schools the right of students
and teachers to freely exercise their
faith will always be protected including
the right to pray so we call this the
right to praise that is what I do
and rollback discriminatory regulations
so we have rules to rollback
discriminatory regulations on religious
service organizations and earlier this
afternoon my White House released a new
memo to make sure a federal funding is
never used to violate the First
Amendment which is a very big deal
with us today is Hannah Allen a high
school freshman from Texas Hannah would
you tell us what happened at your school
with respect to you and prayer so the
next day parents had called into flames
you told us that we could pray but you
said we had to hide in the gym or behind
a curtain or somewhere away from
everyone else and I know that if this
can happen in a small town in Texas it
can happen anywhere and that's not right
no one should feel ashamed of their
faith especially in school so and what
what so what ultimately happened
thank you
we're also joined by Madeleine Marilyn
Raines a former teacher and the founder
of teachers who pray Marilyn if you
could little bit about what happened
yeah so thank you I'm Marilyn Ramsey I'm
the founder and president of teachers
who pray and I found that teachers who
pray because I as a teacher believe in
the beauty of every child and the
unlimited potential that were his eyes
within however the students that I was
getting weren't set up for success
because they were so significantly
behind grade level I found I said one
year it was like 30 32 students getting
killed and I was overwhelmed with the
thought the heaviness of the work so I
thought about quitting and I decided not
to I was going to fight and I was going
to pray and uplift my spirit so I can do
the job that I knew God had called me to
do so
I began praying with other teachers in
the building who are like-minded and we
really support each other build
community built more Hope built more joy
in the work
despite it being so difficult and we
grew like right now there's over 150
chapters the teachers who pray because
teachers need that that spiritual
supporting guidance and today I believe
it's super important because there is a
myth out there that what teachers who
pray does and other organizations do for
teachers spiritual wealth is not legal
and it absolutely is and I'm here to
tell teachers that we need to pray if
your face
we need to pray we need to well cool up
and just do what we have to do for our
kids because they need us and they are
depending on us and if we're not strong
we can't make them strong so that's why
I'm here
that was really beautifully said thank
you very much that's beautiful thanks
Marilyn so while I'm president which
will be hopefully four five years ago
maybe we'll work on what the video will
work on a major extension of that but we
will not let anyone push god from the
public square we will uphold religious
liberty for all and I want to thank you
all and God bless you all for being here
a great time in our country they're
doing things that nobody thought would
be possible I'd like to ask my mic
secretary DeVos and Deputy Attorney
General Rosen to say a few words about
our actions you don't mind thank you for
your leadership your courage and your
friendship to people of faith especially
too many misinterpret a separation of
church and state as an invitation for
government to separate people from their
faith in reality our Constitution
doesn't exist to protect us from
religion it exists to protect religion
from government the First Amendment
affirms our free exercise of religion
and we don't forfeit that first freedom
to anyone or in any place
thanks to your leadership mr. president
today we remind schools of the law with
respect to religious expression
something that hasn't been done in more
than 15 years and where there are
violations we now make clear that the
law requires States to establish a clear
process for students like Hana parents
and teachers like Marilyn to report them
it also notes that the law directs
states to tell us about any and all
complaints as well this administration
and you is and always will be committed
to ensuring all believers have the
freedom to learn to pursue our passions
to use our talents and to live in
accordance with the unique purpose that
God has called us each to do if we
embrace that freedom our faith will be a
light no darkness can overcome thank you
well thank you thank you mr. president
thank you for your leadership on this
really critical issue there are the
fundamental supporting Americans to
practice their faith is so important
it's so appreciated by millions and
millions of Americans and at the
Department of Justice we remain firmly
committed to enforcing Americans
constitutional rights including this one
that's part of why I'm very honored and
privileged to be a part of today's
announcement on the new guidance
document about prayer in school I think
sometimes people don't appreciate that
there are many many Americans who feel
called to pray during the day and our
First Amendment to our Constitution
protects them and sometimes I think
there's a confusion about this issue as
to
trying to force people to pray you don't
want to but that's not what this is
about this is about protecting the
rights of those who do to have the
Liberty to do that on school grounds and
that is protected by the First Amendment
so so today's guidance reaffirms and
clarifies and spells out for Americans
what that freedom is with regards to
prayer and religious expression and I
really think that the courage of people
of face such as the folks we have here
today there's really a reminder of how
important our constitutional liberties
are and the great action that that your
administration is taking to ensure that
that inspiration for the efforts to make
this happen
very good job thank you very much Paula
would you like to say something like
this amazing team and policy and
everyone who has made this this is a
huge thing so he said it is a
constitutional right a First Amendment
right and that's that you continue to be
such a fighter for people's freedoms for
their duties that you often say we work
with God not government perceived and
perception has often been people been
bullied harassed stopped from practicing
their faith you have so many people that
have walked out here very brave with
horrific stories of being persecuted
because they simply wanted to pray and
prayers we know means a huge difference
so thank you for standing
thank you very much yes